and it was contained in a you know
banana box full of chemicals that we
father bought for me from the Nottingham
Post when I was about 11
I wouldn't happen these days no no I
suspect in order to advertise things
aren't anymore so potassium mint metal
is very reactive one of my colleagues
used to work with it described it as
evil it will react so reactive that if
you have it in a box with argon so that
you can't get oxygen from anywhere we
will take the oxygen out of paper which
is paper as a compound of carbon
hydrogen oxygen and you can extract this
so here we have a sample of potassium
it's a really quite nice metal and you
can see very small sample but it's
really soft and you can see it's a bit
like chewing gum you know I can squeeze
it with the pliers so what we're going
to do now is we're going to take the
small sample of potassium and we're
going to react it with water so we've
got a really quite large vessel with
lots and lots of water in here and I'm
going to take this small sample of
potassium and drop it in very very
carefully like sodium it's quite a low
melting point metal and if you mix
sodium with and potassium together to
make so-called sodium potassium amalgam
it's called nak by those who work in the
trade na for sodium k for potassium nak
is a liquid at room temperature it looks
a bit like mercury a silvery liquid it's
very light and I never played with it
but people say that if you try and drop
it on the floor it will burst into
flames before it hits the floor because
it reacts with the water in the air
it's a scale of the experiment you know
we've got massive lump of sodium to a
tiny little pea of potassium which tells
me I need a bigger bit
potassium is very important bodies
contain quite a lot of potassium and
it's in all sorts of biological material
if you burn garden rubbish in the ash
that you get in the end is potassium
which is presumably why it's called
potash so this piece of potassium is
really special because it's a family
heirloom
it belongs to to Neal and he cause Neal
a little bit of a danger or a little bit
of harm you know in his earlier life and
I'm sure when he comes up after molding
it's a nice piece he'll tell you in
first-hand experience about the
reactivity of potassium you hurt
yourself with this teacher so potassium
and water
Neels potassium and water
yeah